mesdames messieurs je tiens en
présentant à vous à remercier
chaleureusement
messieurs les élus locaux qui m'ont
permis ce soir de passer sur vos écrans
en ayant contacté beaucoup d'entre eux
j'ai reçu partout un accueil très
chaleureux et environ deux sur trois
m'ont donné leur signature
ce qui tend à prouver que le courant
fédéralistes que je représente répond
véritablement à des aspirations
profondes du peuple français je
regretterais que deux millions et demi
de jeunes de 18 à 21 ans ne vote pas car
au fond le fédéralisme c'est l'idée de
l'avenir le fédéralisme est tout nouveau
par opposition aux doctrine
traditionnelle
on peut dire que le fédéralisme à lui
seul s'oppose à tous les autres partis
en ce sens qu'il est nanti centralisme
le fédéralisme s'oppose au centralisme
faussement dit libéral autant ou presque
autant qu'ils s'opposent au centralisme
collectiviste l'idée fédéraliste
s'incarne dans le parti fédéraliste
européen et celui ci se trouve
actuellement organisés dans de nombreux
pays d'europe occidentale dont
l'allemagne l'autriche la suisse
l'italie la france
il y à des comités d'organisation en
suède en grande-bretagne en belgique
pour présenter le plus simplement du
monde le fédéralisme
je dirais qu'il est quelque chose comme
un socialisme autogestionnaire
ou encore comme un socialisme libertaire
il se ramasse en quelques idées simples
les idées d'autonomie de participation
de coopération de complémentarité à
l'antagonisme le fédéralisme substitut
la complémentarité
le fédéralisme s'exprime dans les
ouvrages d'alexandre marque disciple de
proudhon et on peut en trouver un
condensé fidèles dans la charte
fédéraliste de montreux
adopté par le mouvement fédéraliste
européen en 1964 une idée maîtresse du
fédéralisme c'est la théorie des
collectivités les collectivités de tous
niveaux et de toutes natures doivent
trouver place dans la société doivent
être institutionnalisé doivent posséder
leurs organes leurs pouvoirs financiers
administratifs et préalable de tout cela
la reconnaissance légale
à côté des collectivités territoriales
telles que le quartier la commune la
province la nation l'europe le monde il
ya des connectivités sectorielle d'ordre
économique social professionnel culturel
en vertu du principe de subsidiarité
tous les problèmes doivent être résolus
autant que faire se peut au niveau même
et dans la société même où il se pose
c'est seulement à titre subsidiaire
c'est un problème une difficulté ne
trouve pas sa solution au niveau où elle
survient que le niveau supérieur est
habilité à intervenir par cette
reconnaissance générale et cette
institutionnalisation de toutes les
sociétés doivent disparaître les groupes
occultes doivent disparaître aussi les
monopoles les multinationales lesquels
doivent être soumises au contrôle
politique d'une instance de même niveau
ce qu'ils appellent donc que l'on fasse
l'europe et même le monde unis parmi ces
collectivités de divers types
il en est une qui soulève à l'heure
actuelle des problèmes sans cesse plus
nombreux ce sont les collectivités
linguistico culturel j'étais je crois
parmi les premiers en 1963 a théorisé la
question des collectivités linguistico
culturel et depuis que de chemin
parcouru tant dans la lutte pour plus de
liberté tant dans la lutte
pour l'émancipation des minorités
linguistiques et nationale que dans la
prise de conscience par l'opinion
française européenne et mondiale des
problèmes de ce qu'on pourrait appeler
le quart-monde le monde des minorités
linguistiques et culturels
on se souvient du cri du général de
gaulle vive le québec libre
et bien si le québec a besoin de
renforcer son autonomie mais ce n'est
pas à nous autres français dans vive et
d'autres groupes ethniques en europe et
en france même éprouvent les mêmes
aspirations les mêmes besoins
les grands partis se sont saisis
aujourd'hui du moins certains d'entre
eux de cette horde de problème mais il
n'en traite encore que de façon
accessoire est d'ailleurs leur doctrine
tout au moins au plan de la propagande
électorale se réduit à quelques grands
mots abstraits sans doute fort généreux
mais comme excuse de le dire assez
banale car ces personnalités
c'est clair cherche à conquérir le
maximum de suffrages et préfèrent pour
seul à parler tout simplement de
grandeur de progrès social de justice de
présence de la france dans le monde la
dépendance nationale ce n'est pas de
cette manière que j'entends mesdames
messieurs m'entretenir avec vous j'ai la
volonté d'être concret ou si bien
terminerais ma présentation en trois
propositions en proférant trois
propositions très nette et concrète que
veut le parti fédéraliste européen
le parti fédéraliste européen réclame
premièrement la construction immédiate
de la fédération européenne
une fédération européenne que nous ne
concevons pas comme une super nations se
sont indignés de droite qui sont très
éloignées du fédéralisme
le fédéralisme qu'on soit l'europe comme
la nécessaire organisation de la
convives ans entre voisins et comme une
étape vers la fédération monte
deuxièmement la transformation de la
france en république fédérative de
région autogéré comme comprennent bien
pas de séparatisme c'est pour sauver la
france et non pour la détruire que nous
voulons une très large décentralisation
troisièmement l'avènement d'une société
fédérale east où les rapports entre les
hommes seront véritablement des rapports
entre hommes libres
[Musique]